good
morning millennials welcome back to the
morning toast happy monday acknowledge
the space that you're in rise and grind
today it's a monday but we're alive
and we've already been so productive
this morning that i kind of feel good
like let's
let's hit this monday hard and it's also
a short week so like how really mad can
we be i know we have a long holiday
weekend coming up every once we
acknowledge that space and we're going
to rise and grind until it's the long
weekend
but we did rise and we did grind this
morning because we recorded an interview
which is going to be at the end of this
episode so we can tell you on the show
with the girls from the bowl type we've
got asia we've got katie we've got megan
we've got
all three all three bowl type girls so
like we
the five of us i would say we were the
bold types we were being quite bold we
were being extremely bold
and if you are a fellow bold typer
then today's episode is for you because
um ahead of their premiere on may 26th
we're
sitting down with them about the final
season and they were just like so nice
and sweet it was
such a treat it was a true delight so if
you're going to listen it's at the end
of this podcast episode if you want to
watch the video we recorded with them
via zoom
it's up on our youtube channel um just
like was really grateful for the
opportunity
yes extremely grateful i feel like my
outfit today is like extremely bold type
very jane
it's very right she loves a puppy
sleeves a bold sleeve a bold everything
and so when i got dressed this morning i
i definitely had that in mind yeah i
forgot that like
you know that they're fashion girlies no
i knew that but i was just like it
didn't occur to me to like join them on
their fashion journey so i just looked
like a regular person
i do try to always dress in theme for
our guests but we're recording another
interview today that will be up on
tomorrow's episode so we're not going to
spoil it yet
and so i had to dress for like when you
know who the next guest is you're gonna
know that it was really hard for me
to not put all my eggs in that pasta i
know i know and i appreciate and i
commend your bravery i really do
it's someone's gotta do it oh bless you
i might haven't sneezed on the podcast
in a while he sneezed on it means i'm
truly brave
true really we have a great show for you
guys a lot happened over the weekend
there was snl the bbmas
taylor's birthday like there was just a
lot of things happening that we just
cannot wait to discuss
yeah it was a nice weekend though i feel
like i had a lot of weekend i feel like
i got i just got a lot of time with the
family i
read a lot i finished my book the
romanov empress it felt so long but it
was just as long as anything else that i
read
and it was really good so if you're
looking for like a great history of
russia from 1860 to 1920
the romanov empress the scenery of maria
durovna i am always looking for a nice
brief history brief history of the
romanov empire from 1860 to 1920. so
the next time i'm searching for that i
will definitely pick that up yeah
because it's like you get the history
but in
a snap well it's not snackable because
it was long but you know like through
the lens of one extraordinary woman
i too had a very robust weekend lots of
family time i went out on saturday night
and just like
got so drunk like i was hungover until i
went to bed last night like
really bad i guess we didn't really chat
that much yesterday because i didn't
know it was really really bad like i
went to bed at 10 o'clock i had like a
splitting headache i just
it was one of my worst hangovers to date
wow was it worth it
yeah okay i i didn't have anything to do
yesterday either but it was the night
fun yeah i was just like desperate for a
good time like i went to a party like i
normally would have left
upon arriving at you know but of course
i stayed for like three hours it was
just like really wanting to get drunk
and like
hang out well you know you did it and
i'm fine and you did just that
and now i'm gonna take it easy this week
before the big weekend
and it's probably time we let you guys
know i know it's a long weekend but of
course
we make a long weekend longer even
longer so our last show of the week will
be thursday and then we'll be back on
wednesday
because we just have like things to do
i'm gonna go on a boat you know like i
have
big mdw plans yeah no it's really my
fault because i have to be out of town
kind of a wedding
jacket is a wedding so like i then took
up vacation on the days that you were
gonna be gone yeah so we'll be back
on wednesday um sorry
it sounds really long when you say it
like thursday to wednesday but
everyone's off
for the most part like friday saturday
sunday monday yes exactly so we just
took
one extra day what actually which we
needed to take so we'll give you extra
content this week to get you through
lots of interviews lots of patreon
speaking of
i uploaded my what i eat in the day vlog
to the patreon
and i think people are really really
enjoying it i know that you did
i actually really did and i do believe
it goes without saying that
um before watching the video uh jackie's
not a doctor
no she's not recommending this for
anyone this is just what she does
i'm just a vlogger so i have to show you
what i eat in a day and honestly people
get those too confused a lot 100
but like if you're not you're not a
vlogger if you're not showing people
what you eat in a day
and you're not a doctor if you're not a
vlogger a hundred percent
and i find what other people eat in the
day like so interesting
so because you just get like good ideas
from other people too so
um i filmed that and if anybody wants me
to record one it will be three hours
long
because i just like eat so much i would
love for you to record one you know what
it's like actually embarrassing because
like the video would be five minutes
like i have a chewy bar in the morning
and i don't eat anything till dinner and
then i eat
4 000 calories for dinner like that's
just me
yeah i i would be curious and also
when you start to have to film like what
you eat a day it's kind of like when you
have to like input your
accountability into new or something you
really start like paying attention
you're like
should i eat that or i'm gonna have to
put on the vlog right so i i definitely
had one of my best days because of a
vlog so thank you guys for holding me
accountable so the vlog was basically
like your
teddy melting cam 100 100 if you want to
eat well just vlog it every day
okay good thing i don't think you'll
have to like post it too and nobody
wants to watch that
no um well we have a great show for you
guys today lots to discuss lots to recap
i'm so excited to talk about snl like i
have so many thoughts so
i just feel like why not get right into
it yeah do you have anything else to say
um
i feel like i always have something to
say we want to wish a very happy
birthday to magnolia today is magnolia's
first
birthday happy birthday knowles bruno's
girlfriend he's looking to take you to
dinner tonight so keep your calendar
open
we love you magnolia even though
magnolia's mom maro
never watches a show so this is falling
upon deaf ears
yes but we're just so happy magnolias
turned one
and we couldn't wish for anything better
for her
and you know what she's really like a
really good girl she's a good girl
and so i'm really proud like she's done
she's had a really hard first year
margot keeps her
in line like margot was the strictest
dog mom ever
but look at manoli she's really like a
great dog yeah speaking of dogs i have a
bruno update that i don't know i told
you and like you really were like shook
by it
and so was i i forgot what it was that
bruno i weighed him this weekend
oh bruno weighed 16 pounds you guys i
just feel like that's a lot of brew
it is especially because my frame of
reference is theo who i believe weighs
somewhere around 25 pounds
so you you cannot tell me that bruno
only weighs nine pounds less
yeah no it was it was kind of shocking
but i was just like
the more the merrier and then it's also
shocking because 16 pounds is like you
would think like
lifting weights or something like 16
pounds is like nothing no but like if
you pick up a
15 pound dumbbell no that feels like
really heavy but compared to brew
i don't know i just thought everyone
should know that make it make sense brew
is growing
into just a lovely young man growing
[Music]
excuse me okay we can get into
everything i don't have snl as a story
so you'll have to slap that in somewhere
you don't
no why everyone's quaking about what you
know it was the final episode of the
season people were curious if certain
cast members were going to be announcing
that they're leaving none of them did
but like
well i guess we could just get into it
right now yeah just tell us your
thoughts quickly i just like
it's nev it's not gonna be a story
unless elon musk is hosting a song
amazing oh that's so funny because i
literally thought it was the best
episode all season i was
in hysterics and yes when i'm hungover
i'm more susceptible to laugh at your
jokes because i'm like just
generous like that but i thought it was
hysterical i thought i learned so much
about anya taylor joy like she's
first of all like so stunning but we
already knew that i didn't know that
like spanish was her first language she
grew up in miami she had a very unique
accent it was like american but like not
um she grew up in argentina like she was
just this woman of the world
and i didn't know anything about her um
she acted so well in all of the sketches
there were
so many funny sketches and weekend
update they do my favorite thing
which is at the end of every season they
write jokes for each other
so like they blindly have to read jokes
that the other one wrote for them and of
course like michael chase always
michael chae always makes the jokes for
colin joe's like really racist
so it was just it was so funny it was a
great episode
and lil na's ex was unbelievable like i
just think he's so talented
and he ripped his pants off i saw the
headlines everyone's like quaking
i thought he was great and you know but
really just like i was thinking when i
was watching him like he really has
created like an entirely new genre like
i don't even know what i would
call his music like it's it's so
different and like his aesthetic is so
different
and i just thought he was great and i
thought it was a really good episode now
a lot of people are speculating
it's a final season like who's leaving
who's staying cause there was an
emotional moment
there was an emotional moment at the
beginning of the episode with 80 kate
mckinnon
um cecily strong and keenan and everyone
well cecily got kind of choked up and
the whole vibe of the show i was getting
like the impression that cecily was
gonna leave which i
am so excited for like i actually think
she's the least funny person like on the
entire show
and that's saying a lot um and also they
gave her like this big
tribute thing at um at the end of
weekend updates it was kind of
it felt like her send-off like she
didn't say or do anything it just had
those vibes
and i endorse like i think that is fully
the right decision
um and then pete davidson came out on
weekend update and just made like a
weirdly sentimental
conclusive kind of speech like this has
been so fun thank you so much for
letting me grow up in front of you guys
bye like it was like i will not be
surprised if he leaves
yeah it's it's honestly surprising that
he's still there
i mean especially because uh he's never
there like he doesn't he was literally
in one sketch and it was actually pretty
funny
but um i really feel like they need to
clean house like in a lot and they need
to like start promoting
other people like i feel like beck
bennett like is actually really funny
and he deserves like more air time
yeah um i really do not think melissa
via senor is funny like at all and i
wouldn't mind seeing her go
um it almost feels like she like does
certain impressions and like forces them
to make her do it on weekend update like
i just don't i don't find her funny at
all i do not find cecily strong funny
at all i think that keenan is great
keenan should stay i think
if keenan or kate mckinnon leave like
the show is [ __ ] like they're like the
actual like celebrity like stars like
that come from snl like
chris and wig or whoever so i don't know
what they will do if either one of them
leave and i don't think either one of
them is going to leave
you don't think but people think people
are speculating that kate mckinnon is
leaving
i don't think she is okay interesting i
agree they could use a little bit of a
shake-up and the ratings stay the same
yeah and just like some of the people
who've been on for a few years like they
just didn't take off
like heidi gardner like she's funny but
like
she didn't she's like not unique enough
in my opinion
got it so just feel like a lot of people
who have been there like and they really
need to make the show
the bowen and um chloe fineman show like
they are the future of the show and
they're hysterical
yeah so that's my thoughts okay cool i
only watched the one sketch
because you and i need to go you guys i
lost my mind that was maybe one of the
best sketches i've seen in like the last
10 years when they said a bra is for
bubbies and a bra is for breasts
i was crying and then when they held up
their two bras i'm like i literally have
that bra like
they were like straps so wide they're a
pair of jeans
it was so [ __ ] funny and so accurate
and when they
gave jill zara and a shout out like it
was just everything that was a brilliant
sketch
yes okay well i might watch the rest of
the episode now it was
very good now that you've raved about it
yeah okay so now without further ado
do to do where are you right here
sleeping being a precious boy
it is time for the past five stories
that you need to know before you wake up
and take a bite out of your morning
toast
well you listen to the sweet sounds no
one can hear it while you listen to the
sweet sounds of construction
we are so excited that today's episode
is brought to you by olive in june the
mani system the answer to salon perfect
nails at home
olive and june polishes last over seven
days and they do not chip
with the mani system each at-home
manicure comes out to just two dollars
and we have a special link for you to
shop at oliveinjune.com
because the hardest thing about doing
your nails yourself is that you can't
you've tried they look like they've been
painted by a five-year-old and salon
manicures are so expensive oh my god i
went to manicure a few weeks ago my
place i guess
you know tough times because of cobit
manicure gel manicures at my
nail salon now are sixty dollars whoa so
i've been forced to
find other options and all of june alvin
june has really saved
my life um the olive and june manicure
system
shows you what diy mayonnaise should
look look like
and that it's possible to have your
polish last chip free for over seven
days
the system comes with all the tools you
need honestly the best part of the whole
kit is the little tools
the cuticle oil is absolutely everything
of the sort of course it comes with a
nail file
but it also comes with a nail buffer
which is just as important and
constantly forgotten
the polishes are beautiful colors
they're all very pliny
but also the polishes come with this um
what would you call it it's like it's a
silicone
adapter that you put on top of the
polish bottles that really keep your
hands steady and you can move it from
bottle to bottle
it's really great yeah it helps you do a
steady manicure it's like training
wheels
yeah the mani system it comes with six
polishes so it breaks down to just two
dollars a manicure
when you used to spend at least 35
dollars for one
gel manicure and in my new place 60. um
our nails have never looked better and
we did them ourselves so get your new
nail life and if you want to get twenty
percent off your first manny system
it is code toast olive and june.com
again that's olivenjoon.com
the code is toast and you get 20 off
your first manicure system
when you use the promo code toast at
olive and june.com
we are done with expensive bad manicures
we are they have the plenius colors
and the game is not forever changed
we're doing manicures at home now like
now that we can we will
we're going to get in the car we're
doing our nails at home
okay first story are you ready it's the
global story
it's is it eurovision it's eurovision
it's truly global
eurovision winners main skin agree to a
drug test
after cocaine allegations okay this is a
crazy turn of events
well let's backtrack because backtrack
most people in america do not know what
eurovision is and i i honestly didn't
know about until last year when i
brian got tickets and we went in tel
aviv like yes and i think for the first
time ever it was
broadcast on peacock so you could watch
it in america and which we did call of
saturday watching eurovision the longest
show of all time but it's a talent show
interesting it's italian global talent
show for every european country it's
like the olympics everyone gets to
submit
one act they write original songs they
perform them all weekend they cut to
finalists and on saturday was a finale
26 countries
performed one is the winner it was italy
it was italy and if you watch
you then you're genuinely shocked by
italy being the winner like when the
scores were coming in and like all the
points were going to italy and
switzerland
and france france deserved it italy and
switzerland i'm like
are you serious like i i was i thought
this was a talent-based competition so i
was kind of confused yeah no it was
definitely based
on nothing other than i don't know
friendships like right because i have no
idea why these people voted the way that
they voted politics but it was
is it political do you really like i was
wondering as i was watching because like
the way these countries were voting made
no [ __ ] sense like no
literally like justice for malta justice
for malta malta was so clearly the
winner from
and israel was in and i of course wanted
israel to win and even i knew that malta
should have won like
malta was everything everyone on twitter
was like it's literally
maltese lizzo like she had such an
amazing voice
such energy such a great song such a
great song and she'd like her girl
dancers like it was just
powerful yeah but there were so many
like great acts and tweeted italy didn't
even
cross my mind wouldn't even be top 15
actually might have been bottom five for
me agree which was shocking
so anyways they won based on whatever
credentials
these people voted based on policy yeah
and then also they got the fan votes
like
no they didn't and malte didn't get a
lot of fan votes yes malta is so small
and of course like
the the bigger countries are at a bigger
advantage they have more people to vote
for them it's a really big deal in
europe like
people wait up all night and they vote
like it's a huge deal so of course
you're gonna
vote for your home country and i just
don't think there are that many
voters from malta yeah perhaps but
that's why the judge votes could
really help but anyways in a strange
twist of events the italian glam
rock band that won the eurovision song
contest returned
returned home sunday to the audition of
fans congratulations from the government
and so much speculation that the lead
singer had snorted cocaine during the
show
that now he's vowed to take a drug test
he said we want to shut down the rumors
the rumors spread on social media after
he was seen bending over a table
during the saturday night live tv
broadcast there's a photo of it a video
of it it really does look like he's
doing cocaine
tv really does so in order to squash the
rumors and not take away from their win
he
is going to do a drug test well i think
i i mean i saw the picture and
was like you cannot tell me that this
man was not doing cocaine but if you
agree to a drug test and it's not even
mandatory because i think
if let's say he was tested positive for
drugs
i don't think he would get his
disqualified no he wouldn't so i just
think he wants to salvage his reputation
yes which i understand
but he doesn't have to submit to the
drug test so the fact that he is makes
me think that he wasn't
right because the picture he could just
let these like rumors find it's just
like this funny thing
but the fact that he's going so far out
of the way makes me feel like okay maybe
maybe not
and i don't think it would disqualify
him in any way this isn't the kentucky
derby but no it's not
like a sport yeah i this he's not medina
spirit
right so i don't know um but i think the
fact that he is agreeing to do it when
literally like nobody's asking him to
makes me think he's innocent but that
picture is very damning it is very
damning but i also feel like i hadn't
seen these rumors until he agreed to the
drug test so i i kind of feel like he's
giving it more legs
yeah but also like when i was watching
him i literally said to you i'm like if
this guy wins he's gonna be the biggest
douchebag in all of italy like he was
just like feeling himself and like now
that he won he like thinks he's so great
um yeah so he's obviously like i just
got the vibe that he was like a douche
and like really like
wants to be famous so i think
so i think like honestly all in all this
is just like part of his image now
yeah no um maybe he's just like riding
this wave and like he's like oh okay i'm
going viral like let's play this out
right that's true also there are a lot
of ways
to get around drug tests especially if
it's not like mandated by the court
like when you have to submit a drug test
like to the government
they like watch you pee there's nothing
you can do to right but if no one's gone
dwayne read one and his sister appears
in the company
yeah there's no one monitoring this
specific drug test like no offense like
why would i believe you
right and i'm pretty sure like cocaine
leaves your body in three days and it's
been three
yeah so if he's like i'll take it
tomorrow unless you do it with your hair
i think like hair drug tests i don't
know i don't know we'll take a look
we'll keep you posted on the results of
this but mostly we just want to talk
about eurovision because it was just
really interesting to watch it was and
it was like nice to watch when you have
no stake in the game like you're just
truly like an
admirer from america but it was really
frustrating because we started watching
it at three o'clock and it was over at
like seven so it was four hours
just for us to literally watch a
competition that was based on nothing
right
truly truly based on nothing because if
they wanted to like if they wanted
someone to win also
like you told us the person who wins
then eurovision's hosted in their
country next year
so maybe like at eurovision they know
where it's going to be next year and
they've got to make that person win
somehow that i could possibly understand
but then in that case they could let
like the fan votes
sort of sway towards like i just wish
the judge's votes were based on merit
it made no [ __ ] sense yeah and it was
just i felt like i wasted my whole
afternoon
and i also felt like at first when
everyone was voting for really terrible
acts i was like oh maybe this is a way
for them to have their country win if
they vote for someone who's like not
really
a good candidate but then everyone might
have had that same idea and voted for
the worst people because the worst
people
were the winners it was so shocking and
it really felt like a waste but i did
enjoy like watching like this global
moment
me too it kind of felt like left out and
i was thinking like if
if we were a part of it like we would
kill it in america you know yeah and we
were also saying that
toast by claudia is actually like a very
eurovision song
it really is because all the songs are
original and they're all for the most
part except even the people who had it
was rock everyone else it's really like
a
dance bop like very you know eric jane
style that's literally what toast is so
i'm just putting it out there like if
somebody wants to license
toast for next year's eurovision in
italy like i would be okay with it
yeah i think that that would that's
exactly the future of toast
i think it is too okay ready for our
next story another wonderful performance
moment
pink pink performed her show-stopping
medley of hits at the bbmas including an
aerial duet
with her daughter willow okay this was
like really surprising to watch it was a
family affair to kick off her medley of
hits at the 2021 billboard music awards
pink hid the stage alongside her
nine-year-old daughter willow for an
adorable acrobatic performance of their
duet cover me and sunshine
then she went on to sing a medley of her
hits but when i first saw him
come on to the stage i was like okay
that's probably her daughter that she's
carrying but then they started going
through the air i was like there's no
way that's the daughter yeah but it was
the daughter
yeah no i know the daughter because i
follow pink on it's almost
no and she's been like promoting this
new song cover me in sunshine so much so
willow's been all over the talk
yeah and i just have to say like adore
pink i'm about to praise her i
absolutely despise that song agreed i'm
literally pink's
amongst her biggest fans like i can't
say enough good things i don't like that
song
i hate it um but not to be negative
i thought it was a wonderful performance
i think like it really kind of validated
what we know about pink but now like
maybe the world will see like she's just
like a star
and she's ready to do the super bowl
that was the that was the message
in case the big wigs at nfl were like is
she ready is she not ready last night
she said
i'm ready and if pink is not doing the
super bowl this year this year i don't
want to see
she'll do it eventually i'm sure but if
it's not this year then i don't want it
no i completely agree first of all her
vocals are on point
her songs are such hits like you oh like
even when her medley which was kind of
small it was only like three or four
songs like
the truckers for pink have arrived yeah
and they're not going quietly and
they're saying super bowl this year not
next year yeah because first of all she
has so many [ __ ] hits that are just
mega man like everyone knows them every
generation it's like
kids on tick-tock know what it's from
anthems
her performing abilities are
unparalleled like truly
and she loves a spectacle like every one
of her concerts is a mini super bowl
the ariel the flipping the harness like
that's what a super bowl is it's a true
spectacle and that is her specialty and
i don't know why
it's taken this long yeah i don't know
why either but she is ready and willow's
ready too because i was truly shocked to
see
that her daughter is an acrobat as well
yeah like that's really i was like
nervous but obviously they know what
they're doing but i was just like
wow i i was i was really impressed you
were
speechless no i was really impressed it
takes a lot to like impress especially
at an award show
yeah like from a kid you know yeah and
she had said before when she was
interviewed on the red carpet she was
like the first three minutes of my show
or maybe
my favorite performance i've ever done
and i was like i feel like celebrities
are always saying that it's like hype
themselves up and i can now i understand
um but let's talk about the bbmas like a
little bit because i was super boring i
watched up until pink performed
me too and then i was like goodbye it
was really boring and it's just one of
those award shows it's like whoever
shows up gets the award like yes
and not a lot of people showed up right
so like oh i wonder who's gonna win the
country
award maybe the only person who's here
gabby barrett won both of them like
it was just obvious and like kind of
stupid and you don't really watch out
for the awards because no offense
they're kind of meaningless you watch
for the performances i saw a bunch i
thought jojo cat was great
i thought jojo cat was great and sizzle
like they're just like a dynamic duo i l
i
love dojika oh good i feel like in
something
like she's just every song is a hit
thanks to tick-tock
every song is a hit and when i was
watching the bbm mains i was just really
thinking like
and i thought this i remember thinking
this last year too like i know every
single one of these songs only because
of tick tock like i've never
heard them on the radio i don't listen
to them on spotify but i know every word
because of tick tock and it's actually
and tanya rad did the um
pre-show she was like the giuliana it
was actually crazy like she did the
whole thing and she did
amazing like she spoke to the jonas
brothers pink literally everyone
she did incredibly and all the
so much of the interview questions like
we're so naturally about tick tock
especially with jojo cat like
it's the impact tick tock has in the
music industry is truly unparalleled
yeah um but the show was boring honestly
yeah it was pretty boring i was happy to
turn it off and get back to my book
um i just want to say like i thought ajr
was really good
i have no idea who that is okay they
sing that song let's go out with the
bang that was from the kardashian
commercials
i don't know it you would know it if you
heard it because even zach knew it and
we're like the oldest people alive yeah
you really
are so um i just want like they i just
liked ajr just want to say that now
you're a big ajr girl
big ajr girlie and the lead singer like
had his own thing going on
no no that was that getting jealous to
say that wasn't my personal thing
um but he had his own thing he was doing
his own thing i respect people who have
their own things and they do
their own thing
no it was it was an interesting um
just sign of the times of like who's
around and who's not around and who's
showing up and who's not showing up it
was nice to see drake
oh i didn't i didn't get that there a
handsome man
i didn't see him i thought nick jonas
did a good job hosting kept the show
moving
i know it pains you to say something
nice about him but it doesn't like i'm
more than happy to say nice things about
nick jonas i just like didn't really
know what he was doing there
you know what i mean yeah he's like too
famous for that no i know and i wondered
why
he even would do that especially because
like hosting is now like the worst job
in the business
but he didn't even try to be funny he
was just like i'm getting you from a to
b i know and i appreciated it
but i do think part of the because i
agree i don't know why he would take it
he's more famous than that and he's
getting awards not giving them out yeah
it was just bizarre i do think that he's
like very eager to do things separate
from his brothers like
be a jonas brother but also be nick
jonas he's in this movie coming up he's
got the space man
like he very much wants to oh yeah he
has pitch yeah he very much wants to be
his
own thing in addition to being a jonas
brother and i think that this was just
one more part of that
i don't understand the eagerness to like
not be a jonas brother when like the
jonas brother is the greatest thing that
ever happened
and kevin jonas like actually looked
really hot last night so i think that's
why
okay cool i agree i don't understand the
eagerness but you know what like
everybody you need to fulfill your
passions
that's true otherwise otherwise you're
resented you're brothers and we are
always always like talking about and and
pushing our passions
forward here at the morning toast and we
should be more supportive of nick jonas
following his passions
i'm completely supportive of him oh i'm
not okay i'm just like being jonas
brother and stop
yeah yeah but sometimes that's not
enough for someone i can't imagine i
can't really
can't [ __ ] relate but i guess that's
how he feels okay am i ready for our
next story
only if it's a story that's brought to
you by hair food it is hair food offers
super simple superfood inspired products
that will make your hair look and feel
amazing
whatever hair texture or hair type you
have hair food has a recipe for you
in addition to their beloved nourishing
coconut milk and chai spice collection
you've got to try some of their new
recipes
the apple cider vinegar herons which is
perfect for days when your hair needs a
gentle cleanse
before conditioning and there's no
shampoo required apple cider vinegar has
so many benefits
for your hair and so i love that they're
using it in their product the rinse is
amazing
also the detangler it's a tumeric and
almond oil detangling milk
it's not just for kids it takes care of
stubborn knots perfect
for like the summer you know when you
get all chlorine in your hair and also
they have a shea butter and pear color
repair concentrate
so if you color your hair and your hair
is maybe slightly over processed
it can make it look vibrant and healthy
all the products smell so good
and all the products are free of
sulfates parabens dyes mineral oils
and are certified peta cruelty free
so if you're looking for nourished
healthy hair it's got to be hair food
look for it at amazon walmart and target
love it
okay next story some fun news kendall
jenner had a star-studded launch party
on friday night for her new liquor brand
818 tequila her famous family including
her sisters kylie kim chloe and her mom
chris
no courtney by the way because she was
out supporting travis came out for the
party at the nice guy in west hollywood
and documented the occasion on all their
social media channels
with some sickening photos other celeb
guests included haley baldwin kate
hudson and katy perry
that's so weird i literally was just
like who's hailey baldwin her name is
haley bieber now like that's how i
literally think
oh that's so true to me they're
interchangeable but bieber is taking the
lead
no but i was like ireland bulbum was
there like i literally did not know who
that was so weird wow um yes so there
are very few things that like i wake up
in the morning and see and like
actually i'm furious that i wasn't
invited to like not in any world that i
would be invited but like
that looked like the best party first of
all it's all about tequila so everyone
was probably just so drunk
kendall really does have like the
coolest friends you know like haley like
i love that crew
and kylie was there she looked amazing
the the stories like i watched kim's
stories a hundred times like
it looked so fun and i just like i woke
up like really sad that like i'm not a
part of that social circle even though
like in what world would i be but like
you know me i'm like delusional like i
was really upset oh wow i was really
happy to like see
this party it's just two different girls
no
yeah yeah i was like i could not handle
being there
like you oh i could you would be great i
would work like for me i just like i'm
just so glad that this is happening like
for them i'm so glad that they're like
sharing content
everyone looks so amazing it did look so
fun there were like fun funny videos
lots of tick tocks made like
great photo moments and they're really
doing the most for 8-1-8 they're doing
as much as they possibly can i know and
it's like difficult because i do believe
8-1-8 is only currently available in
california
so i love the press and i love the
marketing but like i can't even buy it
yeah and it's like at this point i i
mean i probably won't try because i
wouldn't
know like what good tequila is versus
bad but like i'm sure at this point
you're curious
i'm sure it's fabulous like i would
drink it you think so yeah the part
the joe you want to know for sure you
know i'll try it like if i ever get an
opportunity
yeah um also
kris jenner and corey gamble chris's
outfit was so iconic like she was
wearing the 8-1-8 vest
i don't know if that's going to be merch
but like it was all just so brilliantly
marketed because like
need that vest so bad yeah the bucket
hat
everything chris looked so cool like she
looks cooler than anyone there
yeah no they're doing a really good job
of marketing it and
i'm happy for kendall because me too
she's had like i feel like you know it's
always
up until now she's been like the face of
another brand or this or like modeling
for
doing collabs with her sisters yeah
she's never had her own like
big thing like this and and i think it
went really well i saw she bought
borrowed kylie's lip kick truck to do
that
which was just like we love to see the
support i'm sure the kardashians just
own that truck and like they use it
you need a truck for everything for all
your businesses and you know what like i
feel like we don't really know that much
about cannibal but we do know is that
like she gets really anxious
and like so many of her jobs require her
to be away from home and to travel a lot
and like that's when her
anxiety builds up and you know as you
get older you do kind of phase out of
modeling and so i really feel like this
is like a perfect bridge for her into
like another phase of her life not that
she's old but you know what i mean yeah
no you want to
constantly be evolving so i think this
is like a brilliant marketing move i
think the branding is very cool
there is a little bit of controversy so
i have that also there's a texas company
well there's
a lot of controversy about the tequila
itself of course i mean that commercial
was
twisted like whoever literally put her
in that outfit and the hair and makeup
and then also had her sit in a pickup
truck with a broken window with a trash
bag over it like
it was so offensive and so out of touch
it was a charge dress
yes also a texas tequila company um it's
called tequila 512 um the ceo
nick posted to instagram this week
highlighting the similarities between
his brand
and her brand one they're both three
number
names they're made from the same
distillery they kind of have like a same
color scheme
and then the 512 is distilled three
times and eight one eight is just still
twice
and eight one eight costs more than five
one two yeah no there's definitely
something there to his claims like
a hundred percent yeah to me this sounds
like um
kylie lip kit and colourpop oh my god
literally that's a great analogy exact
same product but you're paying for the
brand
same factory yeah same factory
everything huh good call
yeah i haven't got the price yeah yeah
but you're buying like the
the name the name wow that's actually a
really good call
it's a perfect analogy well if if
kylie cosmetics is any indication then
818 will be very successful okay but
also kylie cosmetics right now is
not in operation i think they're like
something biggest coming secret project
but like
i guess if i i can't like go buy a
lipstick right now like the site is
down i know like being transformed i
feel like
they might because i feel like this is
kind of dramatic for a total rebrand
like with new logos and i do feel like
they need a new logo it's kind of
outdated
um i feel like they're becoming like a
clean beauty company you think
yeah or it's going to be like a hub for
all kylie skin like she just trademarked
kylie baby
maybe it turns into kylie beauty and
it's like
skin maybe hair and she just is like
that's a much better idea than mine oh
thank you so much
because like definitely kylie's skin
when it came out i was like nobody needs
this but now i'm like
kyle's skin is everything i use the face
wash and i know like there a lot of like
dermatologists have said like they don't
like some of the fragrances used
but i base my judgment on skin care
for like how it works on my skin and not
like what someone on tiktok says
agreed and with that said i think the
best like influencer skincare right now
is covey
i was talking to emily did an auto
yesterday because you have been i use
the vitamin they have three products
yes i use the vitamin c serum and you've
been like raving about the cleanser but
like i have an open cleanser and i don't
like to have multiple open products oh
i'd use a different
i like rotate between three or four
cleansers but so yesterday i keep it
fresh i finally ran out of my
cerave drugstore um moisturizer and i
didn't have so i went into my cabinet
and i got the cubby one
and i can't believe i let it sit in my
cabinet for like a month because
it's literally the best moisturizer i've
used ever it's so fantastic like if you
truly use one cleanser
then two vitamin c serum and three the
moisturizer
it's you don't need anything else the
whole kit is really gets you covered
from start to finish and
emily genonato is a toaster so like that
makes me like the brand like a little
bit more
but it's really it's a it's a i agree
it's one of the best influencer brands
out right now
i'm not influential i'm almost out of
the cleanser because i also put in my
travel bottle to take with me to like
pritikin
and nashville and i'm gonna buy more
like i love it so much me too this is
not that just
genuine i agree enjoyment of cubby so
i think you're definitely on to
something with kylie beauty it sounds
sounds nice yeah but i think it's gonna
be something big like that so stay tuned
but it's been
it's been like a while the website's
been down like not just since yesterday
for like weeks yeah yeah
agreed so we'll keep you posted mystery
but this is a case for the fbi literally
are ready for our next story
sure because jayla was all smiles with
ben affleck in miami i'm sorry
i love these people well i love jlo i
still don't care like i'm i'm really
really searching
high and low for a [ __ ] to give
and i just don't like okay cool they're
back together like what should i do
go throw a parade i don't know because
up until this point like i really
thought they were just like working on a
new business venture
something but now these pictures are
really pointing in the direction that
you know benefit
is reunited better than ever the one
thing i
i do like have energy for is the fact
that like this is such a slap in the
face to a-rod after he literally slapped
her in the face
like with the whole madison lacroix
thing so i
love that part of it and a-rod is like
obviously spiraling like his posts on
social media have been so weird and also
did he started a makeup company for men
it's called like his and hers because i
saw that picture that was like going
viral which i actually think is not a
bad idea there is some guy on tick tock
i've like seen he's like a small
business who like makes concealer for
men and like
he's literally just got put out of
business um but i thought some of the
promotional um
imagery was very provocative
and very weird i just saw this like
picture of a rod putting on concealer
and it was just kind of disarming and
and he looked very bizarre
and i i can't stress like i actually
think it's a great idea like i
think ben sometimes needs concealer like
he has such puffy under eyes like
i think it's a good idea but like just
something about seeing this picture
really like just threw me through a loop
or whatever the [ __ ] phrases flew me
through a loop no and it's like the
picture
is um kind of jarring but then also like
everyone's talking about this picture
it's actually pretty good in marketing
for his
yes brand he just looks like i don't
know he just looks weird like sitting in
his vanity like putting
on concealer and not to be mean like i
really do believe first of all there is
a space for like
you know men women you know making
makeup yeah
um because they need it like i see
sometimes people on the street with
pimples i'm like girl like i would never
leave my house like that like neither
should you like yeah
yeah why is it okay for you yeah they
need to start putting forth some more
effort like i agree with the mission
behind the company i just can't explain
like why
something about the photo just like
tickled me in the wrong way i agree
i i do agree and i just like i i
actually went from like being obsessed
with with a rod to like wanting to see
him hurt like
i'm so mad at him for what he did to jlo
yeah and i i know that this benefit
thing is definitely bothering him
because like people are obsessed
with benefit in the way that they used
to be obsessed with halo and i know he's
jealous like i know he is and that makes
me happy because i'm
so team jennifer and it's like they were
so obsessed with halo
j-rod for so long that you didn't think
that her next relationship could be
bigger and better but it's actually like
so much bigger so much better and they
have an even better
couple name like benifer it's iconic
yeah no and it like harks back to
and it's just everything and so yes
while i agree like just ben and jennifer
like
whatever whatever but when you add a
crowd to the mix i'm like so yeah so
beyonce
think of how embarrassing it must have
been for jlo to not only be caught up in
some scandal
with her fiance but when that fiance
is talking to like a 25 year old reality
star like that's just i love madison la
croix but it's beneath jlo
yeah and so like whatever a-rod is
feeling right now like he is so
deserving of
yes i'm very upset with him i agree
clearly
we're ready for our fifth and final
story only if it's a story that's
brought to you by better help
it is is there something interfering
with your happiness or preventing you
from achieving your goals
well betterhelp is here and they will
assess your needs and match you with
your own licensed professional therapist
where you can start communicating in
under 48 hours better help is not a
crisis line it is not self-help it is
professional counseling and it's all
done securely online
where you can log into your account
anytime and send a message to your
counselor
then you'll get timely and thoughtful
responses plus you can schedule weekly
video or phone sessions so you won't
ever have to sit in an uncomfortable
waiting room
as you do with traditional therapy
better help is committed to facilitating
great therapeutic matches so they make
it easy and free to change counselors if
needed
it's more affordable than traditional
offline counseling and financial aid is
available
betterhelp wants you to start living a
happier life today visit betterhelp.com
toast that's betterhelp.com
toast to join the over a million people
who have taken charge of their mental
health with the help of an experienced
professional
again if you want a special discount go
to betterhelp.com
toast and you'll get 10 off your first
month so many people have been using
betterhelp that they're recruiting
additional counselors in all 50 states
betterhelp.com toast for ten percent off
your first month
love it okay fit and final stories
little tech news little tech news
snap i don't know if you remember them
snapchat yeah we'll be buying an ar
company wave optics for over 500 million
dollars they're making a big push into
augmented
reality technology really quickly this
reminds me i want to talk about the
wework documentary after this because
okay great snapping said friday will
acquire wave optics a british augmented
reality company
for over 500 million dollars the deal
first reported by the virgin confirmed
by a spokesperson
will help the owner of photo messaging
app snapchat push its way into a future
where ar eyewear could be ubiquitous
they really believe that ar is the
future and they're trying to push it
on everyone i thought that that's what
the snap spectacles were
yeah i just feel like they've been
talking about like ar and vr forever and
like it really never like
took off i agree i agree
like of course and people no but i don't
know anybody who has vr goggles or ar
are they the same thing augmented
reality
virtual reality whatever no i just know
people like who have done it like
experimentally like in their houses like
nobody owns vr and like hangs out in
their vr glasses yeah
i just think this whole augmented
virtual reality was like a trend a few
years ago but it really never took off
and i just feel like maybe it's time to
let sleeping dogs lie
yes but then i was actually in a
conversation last week
about um nfts and i was learning i'm not
in
the world at all but i think like with
the rise of nfts they're
also like ar vr there's like other
worlds that people will be living in got
it
and spending time in and buying
an emotional subject and buying like
things in other worlds
i mean there's another reality other
reality thing just reminds me of that
black mirror episode with landry from
friday night lights where he ends up
like
kidnapping people from his office and
putting them in that virtual like
spaceship and then they find a way
to kill him yeah and he like dies in the
video game
oh yeah yeah no it reminds me of the
black ir
vr reminds me of the black mirror
episode where those two friends keep
playing this video game where
i have not seen it oh my gosh okay so
there's two friends they both put on
their vr goggles and get into a video
game where they each pick a character
that's not like them at all and in the
video game they're playing against each
other all the time and they spend
they're just [ __ ] the whole time like
why they're too um i did not think
that's what you were gonna say
two video game characters like are in
love with each other like they
both these guys are like friends like
buddies from college and they'll log on
why are they like straight
they're straight guys they think like
they're married and like they would log
on at night and like go
[ __ ] their buddies video game character
they were like in love in the vr
and then in real life like they would
never they weren't into each other in
real life but they had this like whole
other life
in the video game and uh they had it
like come to terms with it and i think
the way that it ended was like oh sorry
spoiler alert
um because the wife like found out what
was going on and the way that ended is
like i think once a year they got to
like play their video game and like stop
them crying
and like like see their long-lost lover
that's like brokeback mountain like they
used to only be able to see each other
once a year
also um i just can't i like refused to
support black mirror as an institution
after they they literally destroyed me
when they made me watch that prime
minister [ __ ] a pig
stop because his daughter or the
princess's daughter was kidnapped
and the second he started [ __ ] the
pig to completion which of course he
couldn't do so he had to go for like two
hours
and then they let the princess go i that
was the last episode of black mirror i
ever watched and every couple months
i think about it and it's so upsetting
like
it was the worst thing i ever in my
whole life and i've seen some [ __ ]
it is the worst thing i've ever seen in
my life like it brings me a
i have trauma like real ptsd trauma from
it
yeah i totally agree that was so
unnecessary by the way
nobody asked for that like so [ __ ]
unnecessary yeah
and like the moral of the story is like
because everyone was like like they let
her out like the minute like right
before the vlog has started so if not
everyone was like fixed on their tv
screens they would have known
yeah she was like running through the
shake sick
sick oh my god i honestly i don't know
if i can go on the show like
once it gets in my head i'm like so mad
that we're talking about it because you
don't understand how this
literally haunts me haunts
um but can we talk about the work
documentary i watched it on friday night
because
you told me about it and me and ben were
like i had a lot of thoughts on it i had
a lot of different feelings about it
that's why i'm glad we're talking i
don't know if i said all my feelings on
the show because like on the one hand i
was like
this is dramatic much yeah dramatic much
on the other hand like
this guy was definitely adam was just
like a freak
but that's not a crime no i just think
the whole documentary was
so dramatic and i was like waiting for
him like okay when does he start killing
everyone like they just made it seem
like he was such a bad guy
and he was a freak and him and his wife
the only thing they were really guilty
of
was doing too much too fast like and if
wework had just stayed being wework and
they didn't try to have the schools and
the living facilities like
that was [ __ ] weird yeah but like
people lived there and then they loved
it
those people were so in the happiest
they'd ever been in their lives so i i
thought they
i think like that's what i was i think i
said on the show like they were really
doing that [ __ ] like they were talking
like even the camp like
like they put it on like it's literally
fire festival but they made it happen no
it's not fire festival no i'm sorry it's
what fire festival like
should have like the infrastructure like
they made these things happen and we
were watching and i'm like wow can't
relate to being that big of a loser to
like ever going to a wework summer camp
but these people are having the time of
their lives and like no one's
getting hurt so i just didn't understand
why the documentary like was hell-bent
on villainizing this guy adam
when his really only mistake was
mismanaging his money in his business
and thinking that he was like god-like
and yeah he they were trying to paint
him like a keith ranieri so i'm like
okay when does the branding start
but there was no branding like i feel
like he was a freak and it
definitely sucked that like all those
people got laid off and he walked away
with one billion dollars and is still
waiting for another 500 million from
softbank
to this day definitely unfair yeah again
that's just how these tech
things work people step down to ceo
companies and get hundreds of millions
of dollars like
that's just the world we live in and at
the end when that girl was like
i lost my purpose and like like it was
so unbelievably dramatic i was like
girl it's just a job like it was just i
was not feeling sympathy for these
people at all when like i should have
been i guess
i agree i just thought they really like
trying really hard to find an angle on
this story
when it is actually really interesting
how you go to market at 47 billion
and no one buys your shares and you end
up at 10 billion and there was an
interesting story there
to how they were like you know
considering their numbers like they
weren't
i don't think they were they were being
like just deceptive
in like how they crunch their numbers
and i think that's an interesting story
like for like a financial documentary
but my god were they being such drama
queens and honestly that guy the bald
guy who works for nyu stern he was so
funny
when they were saying like in their
mission statement like we are a
collective of creative and the guy was
like you literally lease
desks like you know it's it's obviously
it's like
and how much they didn't want to be a
real estate company when literally
they're a real estate company obviously
adam never watched the founder because
if he had then he would have known like
the value would have been buying all
this real estate
and then he wouldn't have been a burger
company he would have been a real estate
company yes
but and that's why i always assumed they
owned all the buildings that they
had office spaces in and it made sense
when they didn't because you
he didn't start with a lot of money and
that's why he could just lease these
random floors for like
certain amounts of money per month in
order to buy buildings in the city and
that's what they were saying it is
generational wealth like you have to be
so wealthy to just like pick up a
building or
own a floor like and that's i was like
how did he get started and also
what about the other founder who
literally didn't say one he wasn't even
in the documentary yeah
it was like i don't know i just felt
like they had it out for this guy adam
and i can't stress like if i met adam i
would despise
no and like everything about the we
meant
we grow we live it was so late when it's
like all these like jargon buzz words
that like
mean absolutely nothing like i have no
time for
yeah but i agree with you they really
weren't trying to like shoehorn this
narrative
where it's like it's we all
we all like really we're kind of
pathetic yeah no and honestly like i
feel like
the documentary intended to make adam
look bad but it ended up making a lot of
the people who worked for wework wework
look like some of the biggest losers
i've ever met in my life sorry
i agree the documentary was giving me
nexium vibes because
i all i was thinking was like how
everyone in nexium was a huge [ __ ]
loser
yeah and it wasn't even like a cool
celebrity cult it was like your most
famous person is a girl from
smallville smallville like get better
celebrities like and that's how i felt
about this documentary i'm like where's
the drama like what's the t
like i know but you know what the t was
a little bit like ashton kutcher
oh going thank you so much for bringing
that up because the next day me and men
watching on friday night we're walking
to lunch and we're still talking about
it and i'm like
honestly i feel like they tried to paint
adam newman to like look like a loser
but at the end of the day the
documentary was worse for nobody than it
was for ashton kutcher like
going on this pr like
loser dumb tour i was like honestly
aren't you embarrassed like to be
associated
also it wasn't great for gwyneth paltrow
rebecca adam's wife is her cousin
and so she was like this freaky deaky
like hippie like we grow we live all
these things
she's like we're not going to be done
until we change the consciousness of the
world and so she did like a
group like panel or something so like
gweneth was in the documentary it wasn't
great for gwyneth but
it was really honestly embarrassing for
ashton kutcher like he should
never leave his house again but he will
yeah you know that he will
yeah i agree i had uh mixed feelings
about it and it just wasn't so
like why was everyone so hyped up about
a like a regis office space
concept no like why why was it even 47
million like
that's the marketing that's on silicon
valley no but that's the marketing that
was like adam's
that's what he brought to the table it
really was like people wanted to live
there like yeah
it was this like cult-like community but
they weren't hurting anyone so it's not
a cult
yeah and i'm sorry like if you agree to
live in a we live like
that's on you we're all grown adults
like it was really weird
yeah when when he was like i would have
friends come over and they would never
come back like
obviously like what are you doing it was
so bizarre
i completely agree so i said what i said
and i thought it was really [ __ ]
weird
and i thought the documentary was just
trying to make a mountain out of a
molehill and maybe we're just
conditioned
to watch documentaries where things are
supposed to our
sometimes yeah i guess it is interesting
we used to see the headlines about we
work i think we reported on some of it i
don't think we ingested anything that
actually happened because this was all
news to me
so yes it is nice to know what happened
but i agree maybe we're just conditioned
to like expect the craziest [ __ ] from
documentaries and there wasn't anything
that crazy
it was a big fat [ __ ] nothing burger
nothing burger
with a little loser sauce no a little a
lot
um so yeah i would recommend it though
honestly like the documentary because
like
it was interest like there were
interesting parts of it because and i
think for me what was interesting is
like
with all this like tech companies and
stuff and these valuations like they
really don't ever make sense to me and
like never
i couldn't wrap my head around how a
company like we worked that actually was
really successful and like people were
in the door and people are it's a great
idea
they couldn't get enough space like you
know how like 200 locations
right how that becomes
not profitable right well that's the
whole thing like uber doesn't make any
money that is something i'll never
understand but now
they're under new management wework is
still in business i i feel like they
didn't make that clear enough i'm like
so is this company out of order
right but i also had the thought i don't
know if i said this on the show already
if they could have like chugged along a
little longer till covid
and then everything hit the fan they
could have made it seem like
covid was the reason yes but i was
thinking that during the documentary too
i'm like well this company was going
under regardless because working from
home like your whole business is out
your whole business is out no one's
going into the office let alone with a
million strangers in a commune
right literally and
by the way even if covent hadn't taken
them down
the culture now around working is so
different that
honestly the concept of shared workspace
is a little outdated now we're all
working remotely we're not rubbing up
against strangers no they wouldn't have
survived and on a new basis who we're
going to be next
it's the antithesis of a post-pandemic
world and but i think that if they could
have
gotten to march 2020 they could have
blamed it on that they could have blamed
it on that
like so many companies will do and have
done becca cosmetics first to go
um okay so let's cut the chit chat and
get onto our interview
yes so if you're watching um on youtube
there's another video
just next on our channel it is the bold
type we've got cat
jane sutton the girls are back together
and it was really really awesome to talk
to them and if you're listening as a
podcast just keep listening
and thank you guys for listening to the
show we'll see you tomorrow enjoy bye
you